hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to boogeyman I'm ready
for night six it's gonna be a lot of fun
but I got my one punch man sweatshirt
that one of my friends got me leave a
like below if you like one but yeah like
comment and subscribe for one punch
seriously one punch man is amazing you
guys should really watch it it's totally
amazing or read it either one but I'm
gonna continue boogie man and we're
gonna do this well because I got my
strategy of looking behind me because if
you face the enemy head-on that's when
you know you're gonna die oh she sums is
this this is such as us as a calm down
buddy okay
damn I am not prepared I'd started five
nights at candy's
yeah I'm sorry
what's wrong I fell asleep with it
turned on battery's dead I I think
there's some more under my bed working
he's coming
do be filling it could be just a bird or
something don't go near the window
why are you doing don't open it out see
it's fine nothing bout here it'll be
that stupid owl again mean doesn't live
that was both at the same time dramatic
and creepy and then not at all dramatic
and creepy I have no idea who's going on
there but something bad apparently
happened to them
oh no oh god oh
oh no whoa oh boy
Oh buddy boo oh bumper dumper Oh
bing-bong Oh God oh okay the good thing
is it's quiet
nevermind my hopes have been dashed go
away please that's not good well I see
you there creeping in my window like a
loser
oh they climb anymore what else
snatching my people up ooh
I heard that oh man I'm chewing through
way too much battery right now ha ha ha
whoa whoa where am i well guy got him
wait what was that I got him out of the
window what happened
why was he glowed longing what happened
this didn't make any sense why did I die
that's not fair this is [ __ ] I call
him I'm calling the Congress the
Congress to ban this game and it's
baloney what the hell happened was it
because I was looking backwards they did
not like that
get out here okay this is some Bologna
there's there's some malarkey level of
activities going on here ba-ba-ba-ba-ba
malarkey
malarkey now I got to silent I'm gonna
die not today maybe I could yeah nope
oh oh oh creeper in my door
maybe if either twice he was there twice
Oh God
oh that's terrifying oh god go away oh
god I'm running out of Bailey
here's too much battery I'm dead I'm so
dead
he's way too much I need to go for a
battery soon oh whoa whoa that was
silent Oh what the hell happened whoa
whoa ah battery thank you I guess
can I get backup now oh god I'm dead I'm
dead Oh God
oh my god that's so scary oh this
battery was useless it was like non
battery I can't see a damn thing
I'm dead
a million I'm hahaha oh my god it filled
it full
so hard it's so hard it's so hard oh my
god
that is challenging oh god I got oh god
come on get back up aah
oh jeez oh waste goddamn waste not gonna
give me any thing I need whoa hey okay
Oh God please get up get up get up get
up get up get up get up get up Oh God
Oh Frick come on I'm dead a million ways
I'm dead oh come on thank you but not
enough whoa
thought I saw well that's not good
Oh Frick I'm dead there's no way ha
come on what the baloney
ah such bull
oh-oh-oh-oh I wasn't even aware of the
time god damn I did it god that was hard
the trick was you just couldn't let him
open any of the things because I had to
like tune in very closely with the sound
rude have been so screwed so god damn
and those with no noise so I imagine
that if there's another one after this
and the next night it's gonna be like
the same thing except so much noise so
god it's gonna be impossible so I don't
even know if I'm going to be able to do
that but thank you everybody so much for
watching I'm gonna get to five nights at
candy's real soon but I'm also headed
back to LA as of tomorrow so this is
probably one of the last videos that
I'll record while I'm here in Cincinnati
so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I'll see you in
the next video bye bye ha ha oh good
timing though
closet door why go